tweet like i found a pretty funny it's
like a top tweet but like seven weeks to
remove all cultural significance and
impact remove all storytelling weight
and aspect and essentially cannibalize
the work of someone with actual
creativity oh damn then you put in bold
creator economy
the best part about this too is that
like it's
saying like netflix's squid games took
this long to make
and and this long to hit 100 million
views or whatever and then mr mr beast's
remix
mr bezos mr no mr based
mr b mister bass
mr baste is a [ __ ]
youtuber yeah mr mr best
ruffles based anyway but he just ripped
it off that's the thing yeah
and this is no shade man no no shade at
all it's like it's still massively
impressive to make anything that hits
100 million views in four days that
could be the most impressive thing ever
in content honestly yeah like the scale
at which he did this yeah
was so impressive like the fact that
every set was just as big and just as
grand as the real thing and he did that
in
yeah seven weeks like that's [ __ ]
crazy that was another really corny one
that i saw that was like
please like another stupid mic drop
tweet that was like soak in youtube as
it stands now
because mr b squid games just changed
everything
have you ever watched a movie yeah
you ever seen one of those they're
pretty [ __ ] wild
millions of dollars sometimes goes into
those movies like a marvel movie for
example watch that if you haven't seen
one of those wow yeah that'll really
blow your mind yeah
it's like yeah i get his one he's one
guy he's not a full-on production
company but like he is now so yeah
putting three and a half three and a
half million dollars into something
yeah
isn't crazy like that crazy i mean it is
crazy
i just said it's probably the most
impressive thing in content
but 100 million
views on one video in four days is like
unheard of
yeah no that part i mean you know it can
be both but it's not yeah this whole
just changed everything no it didn't
yeah exactly no it didn't if i had five
million dollars i could
construct a game show that is i don't
know
tic-tac-toe but with cars that you blow
up and i'm sure that would garner a lot
of you i don't know man it's like
he obviously has it figured out and he
has the capacity to do it but uh
creative people with similar money i
would venture to say
could could hang with the boy yeah yeah
and and i wonder if like what they mean
is partly because he shot it like a
normal youtube video like that was what
kind of threw me off about the whole
thing i started watching it and i'm like
clearly so much money went into this and
effort but so why are you shooting it
with like a dslr
i mean he knows what his people like
so maybe that's what they mean is that
like he kind of changed the landscape in
terms of like the format where it's like
now we get this crazy high production
value stuff but it still feels like
youtube
yeah
but i didn't like that i would have way
rather seen it shot on like a cinema
camera yeah i wanted to know all like
the 10
people that just left and he's like if
everyone leaves now i'll give you two
grand it was just half the cast being
like bye
yeah like what what
yeah what i would have liked to gotten
to know some of the people you know they
could have they could have played that
out a little bit not just these random
like how you feeling about everything
i'm nervous and they just cut them off
yeah i don't know it's still a feat like
you can't you can't hate on the guy i
think the commentary is really
definitely stupid from people though
trying to make it you know
more than maybe what it is the funniest
thing to me though is the dude who
created squid game
you know how shitty it must feel to like
spend years developing like some art
that you like really believe in and then
it finally sees the light of day and
then a bunch of [ __ ] snot-nosed kids
with dslrs come in like dude we're gonna
do the exact same thing and then they do
it and you have people get on twitter
and be like this just changed everything
it's like no [ __ ] i changed everything
exactly i made it yeah you took my [ __ ]
that was my main gripe with this tweet
it's that it's a remake of the thing
that you're criticizing it's the whole
reason why this exists is because that
guy spent
[ __ ] 100 or 10 years making this
[ __ ] thing
to me it's like when people bag on like
a little pump
they're like
oh anyone could do that it's like no no
anyone can do that now because he did it
and he found something that people like
and as asinine as you want to call it he
still made something that people go damn
this kind of like i just hit somewhere
for me a little pump yeah like i'm just
saying like out of everyone that you
could have brought up because i'm
picking i'm very surprised that little
pump is like because i'm picking the
thing that everyone like the most go-to
like i could [ __ ] do that or oh this
is what rap is now it's like it's like
it has all this like dumb-ass criticism
where it's like
yeah sure but he you can't deny he did
figure out something for a moment and
people were [ __ ] into it and i hate
when people like look at that and go
dude i could [ __ ]
i could rap like this it's like
yeah but you didn't know you could do
that until he did it yeah yeah i'm
saying yep that's totally fair so like
in this same capacity people could look
anyone with like a bajillion dollars
could go oh dude i'll just i could put
that on yeah it's like well now you know
you can put that on because someone
opened that [ __ ] door for you yeah so
that's the [ __ ] that gets on my nerves
when
people have all these like you know
quote smart things to say and it's like
dog
there's one person who took the gamble
on it
and now you know that's possible yeah
you know so what it what really is dope
about this is like you said
traditional
hollywood and and traditional ways of
making content would have made this a
ten part series yep they would have
gotten bts on those people that left and
they would have made that a whole
segment yeah and uh
so on and so forth right yeah and they
would have shot up with a cinema camera
like i said and they like he would not
be probably such a like he wouldn't just
be walking through they'd probably try
to remake it like the netflix one and so
on and so forth but for him to spend
three and a half millions of dollars on
this and then just drop it as a
20 minute youtube video and never refer
to it again yeah never like milk it for
everything it's worth yeah
kind of is game changing
cause he's on to the next one now he's
gonna do something else oh yeah he's
doing his like creator games or whatever
you know what i'm saying yeah so it's
like for him it's like
he's spending money on this stuff but
he's still iterating just as fast yeah
it was just a kind of a drop in the
bucket for him he's like yeah 100
million views i can do this in seven
weeks and now i'm on to the next thing i
want to say he changed the game so much
as i think he proved that he can
innovate on his own style
like he can keep like like you're saying
like this fast iteration he can keep
growing within this premise that he's
kind of set for the type of content that
he makes yeah like i don't think anyone
um
like
to mr b's credit and like the point i'm
trying to make i don't think anyone
would know that they can make a video
like this yes yeah you know yeah like
he's proving like oh no like my format
works even at very big levels
so he should [ __ ] just do this with
every
netflix show that pops off
yeah i mean yeah just remake that [ __ ]
but with youtubers yeah i mean that
would be the worst thing ever in the
world to do
and as soon as i said that i just
regretted it full-on but yeah no he
should do that yeah he should he should
remake the show you and stalk
women and i just meant like every show
that people really enjoy and that is
like culturally significant and he just
comes in he's like we're gonna plug
youtubers into this instead and it's
like oh no
what's up guys i'm mr beast welcome to
the mrb's narcos challenge
i took 10 of your favorite creators i'm
gonna see if they can get these bags of
cocaine across the border that actually
won't be sick i'd watch that i'd [ __ ]
watch that yeah just to see who would go
to jail yep
you